you
we know that the snake is utilized
conceptually and metaphorically as
representation of transformation right
because the snake is something that can
shed its skin and be reborn we know that
a snake is something that's innately
attractive and terrifying to human
beings and other primates so that if you
come across a snake you're likely to be
at least startled if not horrified by it
but also attracted to it in a way that
is underneath your voluntary
consciousness right because snakes
attract orienting reflexes and they
activate the systems underneath your
consciousness that actually governed the
structure of that consciousness we know
that the snake can be well represented
as well as internal chaos so imagine
this imagine that it's not unreasonable
for a self conscious mind searching for
a mode of self representation to remark
on the parallels between the structure
of the snake and the spine and the brain
given that a snake is essentially a
spine with a brain and then imagine as
well that the most archaic aspects of
our nervous system those that govern
novelty and orienting and anxiety
responses are in fact precisely those
that were described by MacLean as nested
inside the reptilian brain and then
imagine along with the Hindu Yogi's that
the purpose of Kundalini Yoga is to
activate the circuitry that's associated
with that snake so to speak to produce a
permanent state of alert wakefulness
that's associated with consciousness
so imagine this imagine an animal like
like a zebra grazing mindlessly in the
herd with no consciousness whatsoever
and then imagine it's relatively
undeveloped cortical structures
activated suddenly by the movement of a
lion off in the perimeter and then
imagine for that brief moment that that
zebra is actually conscious a state that
requires a tremendous amount of energy
and difficult to maintain but because
the threat and the uncertainty manifests
itself within the Zebras mode of
consciousness it wakes momentarily and
then imagine that human beings are like
that zebra always because we've become
self-conscious because we know that the
unknown is around us all the time even
when we think we're safe we're never
safe imagine that the reason we're so
conscious is because as a consequence of
our discovery of the possibility of our
own mortality all this underlying
circuitry that in other animals is only
apparent when they're startled or afraid
or interested or curious in human beings
it's on all the time and that's what
makes us conscious and the reason for
that is because we developed enough
cortical elaboration to note that we're
always threatened by everything that's
around us and then imagine that well
that's pretty awful isn't it because
it's at the basis of all our innate
existential terror but then imagine as
well that without that terror pushing us
forward and and our constant reference
to the dangerous aspect of the unknown
we would have never been motivated to
produce the kind of societies that we've
produced which are essentially very
remarkably elaborated devices that
enable us to find some protection from
that unknown and to manipulate it
effectively and then remembering that
story will return to Genesis Jung says
the snake is was regarded by early
Gnostic Christians as a kind of deity
whose faculties were more developed and
advanced than the original deity that
actually structured the world the idea
there being that the world initially was
a pretty dismal place ever
wasn't conscious we all existed at the
level of the animal and then the snake
came along and said wake up wake up and
the movement from that state of
unselfconsciousness paradise to this
profane state of awakening can be
regarded not so much as a dissent but as
an asset of sorts even though a painful
one and then you have dirt this
commentary from mephistopheles his
representation of Satan and his capacity
for temptation who says follow the adage
of my cousin snake from dreams of
godlike knowledge you will wake to fear
in which your very soul shall quake a
statement associating the human tendency
to attribute to all revolutionary
sources of new information a kind of
demonic being and then you have the
problem of the woman now we know that
within the context of the
judeo-christian tradition women have
unduly suffered for their role in
tempting humanity in the embodied form
of Adam towards higher order
self-consciousness and their do you
think well let's just take a look at how
human beings and their mating
relationships differ from those of other
animals like chimpanzees to whom we are
very closely genetically related and if
you look at the mating strategies of
female chimpanzees you see that they
really don't care who they sleep with so
to speak any old chimpanzee will do now
the less dominant male chimps tend to be
chased away by the more dominant male
chimps but if a female and less dominant
chimp can get the hell away from the
watchful gaze of the dominance hierarchy
they're perfectly happy to mate human
females are not like that
they're selectively mater's and there's
a tremendous body of evolutionary
psychological information that suggests
that although both genders value
intelligence and physical appearance
females value the ability to attain
dominance hierarchy status in men far
more than men admire the ability to
attain dominant status in women which
to say that men don't care what a woman
has with regards to potential for
attaining status
whereas with women it's one of the
strong determinants of mating preference
so then let's say look we don't know why
the hell our cortex is expanded so
rapidly somewhere between five and three
million years ago let's offer this as a
hypothesis the women started to get
choosy and because they were so damn
complicated the whole human species had
to exaggerate its cortical growth prior
to any even use for that cortical growth
just so that the men had an even hand in
the competition right so women put
tremendous selection pressure on the
human being to develop tremendous
tremendous cortical expansion now we
already know that from the mythological
perspective that women are frequently
cast into the same conceptual domain the
temptress domain as the benevolent
aspect of the unknown and we know as
well from representations of hero
mythology that it is the individual who
goes out to confront chaos who's most
likely to free from the dragon not only
treasure but a virgin say in the case of
mythological representations like Saint
George and the dragon
in the Old Testament in Genesis there's
no there's this notion that not only did
people become self-conscious because
they did something but they did this
voluntarily right they think they made
this decision on their own so Milton
puts words into God's mouth and says
soul will fall he meaning the human
being and his faithless progeny whose
fault whose but his own ingrate he had
of me all he could have I made him
Justin right sufficient to have stood
though free to fall and then you think
well maybe the notion of the heritable
sin of Adam characterizing human beings
and their fallen existential condition
isn't just the black-hearted ravings of
fundamentalist Southern Baptist lunatics
right there's something to this human
beings are the only creatures that seem
to live at odds with their own
experience and it's not so unreasonable
to suppose that it's our dawning
capacity for self consciousness that's
put us in that uncomfortable position so
why do I associate the eating of the
Apple with self consciousness well it's
because that's how this story lays
itself out you have the collateral
evidence of the Buddha's story of
enlightenment right his contact with
death you have multiple media medieval
representations of Eve offering to
animal to Adam not an apple but a skull
you have multiple representations of the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil
in medieval iconography as not
containing apples but containing skulls
and you have this the statements that
are within the context of Genesis itself
and the eyes of both of them were opened
and they knew that they were naked and
they sewed fig leaves together and made
themselves aprons well there's a lot of
information packed into those two lines
right what does it mean to have your
eyes open well half your brain is visual
cortex it's not unwrapped it's not
unreasonable to presume that that means
a quick a quick magnification of
consciousness you're conscious during
the day that's when your eyes are open
what happens when your eyes are open
well you know you're naked well what
does that mean well you know you're
vulnerable right to social comment to
social judgement to dominance hierarchy
status maneuvering and to all the
terrible things that the unknown world
can can wreak upon you and so then what
do you do well you create culture right
and that's what this little sentence
says and they sewed fig leaves together
and made themselves aprons that's a
pretty eventful sequence all crammed up
in two little sentences so then what
happens I think it's extremely
interesting
so before Adam and Eve figure out that
they're naked they're cruising around
the garden having a fun time doing
whatever they want they don't take any
thought for the future right they don't
have a prefrontal cortex they're living
in a in a paradoxus environment like an
animal lives well what happens after
they become self conscious well prior to
this Adams walking around with God right
and you think about what that means that
means something like this an animal
isn't in the world of good and evil an
animal like nature points out is beyond
good and evil right enraptured and
entirely by the actions of automatic
instinct governed by processes that are
completely transcendent the animals
nothing but a force of nature there's no
opposition between the animal in the
world the animal is the world and just
as in the case of the animal prior to
the eating of the Apple Adam walks
around the garden with God there's no
discontinuity between him and and the
transcendent world as such but as soon
as he becomes naked he hides well why
well that doesn't need to be answered
all you have to do is think about it why
would you hide if you know you're naked
it's simple you hide because you think
you can get hurt you think that whatever
you are is so vulnerable that if it
shows itself to the transcendent to
others to the natural world that
something terrible will happen and then
you think well that's a pretty logical
presupposition right
get us so God comes cruising around the
garden after Adam and Eve eat the apple
in the cool of the day and Adam and Eve
hide themselves among the trees of the
garden and God says to Adam hey where
are you
and Adam says I heard your voice and I
was afraid because I was naked and I hid
myself and that story has bottomless
depth because it means something like
this at the beginning of Genesis there's
this notion that there's a transcendent
relationship between the individual and
God right the identity of logos and the
individual right a notion by the way
that our entire idea of intrinsic human
right is predicated on as we've been at
some pains to demonstrate a relationship
between the limited and the limitless
eradicated by the dawn of
self-consciousness so what does that
mean well let's say you have a destiny
just for the sake of argument right
because you are a being with a
tremendous history and an unbelievable
potential so let's say you have a
destiny just for the sake of argument
what would cause you to hide from that
destiny well obviously your own
reflections on your mortal vulnerability
right how could I be characterized by
any transcendent power whatsoever when
I'm susceptible to social alienation
right when I have this body which is
capable of terrifying degeneration that
will eventually decay into old age and
that is bounded by death how could I be
good for anything which is precisely
what this little story says and so God
figures out that Adam and Eve ate the
fruit and that's a pretty decisive move
because once you wake up sorry you're
awake and he says and this is not an
injunction by the way this is a
description all right you've done it now
unto the woman he said I will greatly
multiply thy sorrow that I can
option in sorrow shalt thou bring forth
children why why well we have a big
cortex right really big it grew fast and
what that meant is that there was an
evolutionary arms race between skull
size date of birth and pelvic diameter
girth the wider the pelvis the less
effectively you can walk the larger the
skull the bigger the brain the younger
the baby the more dependent and
vulnerable so what do we have in the
case of human beings the female human
pelvis has already stretched to the
limits of its structural capacity so the
hole in its center is as big as it can
get without compromising the structural
integrity of the pelvis while still
allowing women to walk and run so how
have babies adapted to that well that's
simple a mammal of our size should have
a gestation period of two years we have
a gestation period of nine months why
you got to get the damn baby out before
its head gets too big what does that
mean well means it's vulnerable right
nothing more vulnerable than a baby
human being except maybe a baby kangaroo
right but it's got a pouch to hide in at
least so we're born vulnerable right
characteristic of the birth of the hero
who suffers in childbirth women why baby
skulls just a little bit too big has to
be crunched and compacted during birth
right the skull bones aren't joined
together so that the baby's head can be
squashed and visibly deformed during the
process of birth prior to the 20th
century what was the death rate among
women giving birth one in three one in
five terrible why that's the price you
pay for self-consciousness and thy
desire shall be to thy husband and he
shall rule over thee this is not an
injunction this is a description the
additional burden that dependent
offspring place on women place them at a
disadvantage what's the consequence of
that from a historical perspective well
any feminist can answer that question
right and unto Adam he said because you
listen to your wife and have eaten the
tree
of which I commanded thee saying don't
eat that cursed is the ground for thy
sake in sorrow shalt thou eat of it for
all the days of thy life fair enough
right
once you're self conscious you work why
animals don't work why do people work
well because we know right we know that
if it isn't going to happen today it's
gonna happen tomorrow and if it isn't
gonna happen tomorrow it's gonna happen
next week or the week after the month
after the year after and we bloody well
better prepare so that's what we do
constantly prepare and prepare and
prepare so we're not bounded and
motivated by what's happening from
second to second like the animal is in
it's still paradisal state we're
constantly tormented by an endless
string of what-if questions because when
we look at the unknown we can see the
possibility for everything including our
own punishment our own torment our own
demise and so we're motivated like no
other animal to work and so we work but
that is another aspect that alienates us
from paradisal being thorn and thistles
shall it bring forth for thee and thou
shalt eat the herb of the field in the
sweat of thy face shalt thou eat bread
till thou return unto the ground for
dust thou art and unto dust shalt thou
return right therefore the Lord God sent
him forth from the Garden of Eden to
till the ground from whence he was taken
so he drove out the man and he placed at
the east of the Garden of Eden cherubims
and a flaming sword which turned every
way to keep the way of the Tree of Life
Adam and Eve right the mother and father
of all humanity so you can give them a
mythological slant and you can say Adam
is culture say and Eve is nature because
they're the archetypal parents it's a
perfectly reasonable interpretation they
have twin sons Cain and Abel so let's
read first born creatures first born
human creatures in the new self
conscious world so what are the first
two individuals in the new self
conscious world like and let's find out
and Adam knew Eve his wife and she
conceived and bare Cain and said I have
gotten a man from the Lord and again she
bear his brother Abel the younger
brother and Abel was a keeper of sheep
but Cain was a tiller of the ground and
in the process of time it came to pass
that Cain brought of the fruit of the
ground an offering unto the Lord okay so
we're gonna remove this from its this
story from its entrapment in a
particular temporal domain and within a
1000 culture way to say something like
this well if you work you make
sacrifices right that's what works all
about and the reason you make sacrifices
is because you're offering up to the
unknown the fruits of your labor in the
hope that as a consequence of your
diligent effort you're going to be
favored right because otherwise why work
the point of working is to transform the
transcendent into something benevolent
so you work and you work and you work
and you say is that sufficient and the
answer you get from the transcendent is
the answer now it's certainly true that
lots of people work and doesn't go all
that well right they make sacrifices and
they do what they think they have to do
and their life is one string of
catastrophes after another all right so
we have this situation in the process of
time it came to pass that Cain brought
of the fruit of the ground an offering
unto the Lord and Abel he also brought
of the firstlings of his flock and of
the fat thereof and the Lord had respect
unto Abel and his offering so what that
means is that old Abel working away man
things are going great for him right
fortune smiles on him he's doing
wonderfully he's got everything he needs
well old cane he's scrounging away in
the ground and things aren't going as
well for him at all right plagues low
you name it farm life isn't going well
so what happens well Cain was very wroth
and his countenance fell precisely right
because if you work diligently towards a
certain end and you don't get there then
your countenance fell falls right you're
angry frustrated disappointed hurt
anxious threatened ashamed guilty the
whole panoply of negative emotions and
that's fair enough because of course if
you fail that's what's going to be the
consequence but then there's this little
twist on it right this specifically
human twist but it's like that kind of
moral of the whole story and so you find
the Lord saying oh you know what's
what's up with you why are you so
unhappy if you just start your act
together then you'd be accepted if you
really got your act together which is a
statement something like this if you
keep making sacrifices and the same
terrible thing keeps happening
there's always the possibility that
you're just actually not doing it the
right way and if you just get yourself
straightened up top together right and
drop the preconceptions that you don't
really need and adjust your behavior
accordingly then fortune would smile on
you and that's exactly what the Lord
says to Cain right
you don't walk around with such a crabby
look on your face
if you did well you'll be accepted and
if you don't do well sin lies at the
door so what does that mean well this is
a deep motif in ancient Hebrew thinking
if the world isn't laying itself out in
a manner that you find acceptable you're
faced with a tough choice either the
world is a terrible place bent on your
destruction or you're doing something
wrong and it bloody well better be that
you're doing something wrong
because if the world is a terrible place
bent on your destruction you've got
absolutely no hope and Cain talked with
Abel his brother and it came to pass
when they were in the field that Cain
rose up against Abel his brother and
killed him so what does that mean well
it's pretty easy it's simple
it means this well say things aren't
going that well for you
and it's really not because life's
unfair and everything stacked against
you it's because you're kind of a
arrogant stubborn quasi totalitarian
cowardly idiot and as a consequence of
that the world is turning into something
resembling a wasteland around you you
have this option change or continue or
you have another option
man look around there's all those people
doing well the world is a terrible place
bent on my destruction wouldn't it be
just the most interesting thing if as
things are going to hell for me I could
take along just for the ride some of
those successful people who are
successful just for unfair reasons
anyways right so instead of using all
that negative emotion as a cue that
there's something about me that might
need to be transformed I can say well
why not just eradicate the target of my
resentment right not only because that
sort of removes the problem of
comparison but more profoundly and I
think sort of again olymic Lesley
profoundly let's say you make the
decision that the world is a terrible
place and it's bent on your destruction
and then you think well what's the
logical response to that and then you
think something like this
Goethe vows Natha star filiz credo the
spirit I that endlessly denies and
rightly too for all that comes to birth
is fit for overthrow has nothing worth
where for the world were better
sterilized thus all that's here is evil
recognized is gained to me and downfall
rune and sin the very element I'd
prosper in and Goethe draws our
attention to this credo not once but
twice in his writing of Faust and has
mephistopheles say right once again go
on to share nothing past with know made
one what matters our creative endless
toil when had a snatch oblivion ends the
coil it is bygone how shall this riddle
run as good as if things never had begun
yet circleback existence to possess I'd
rather have eternal emptiness and so
then you think about Cain like figures
like Stellan and you think well what
exactly was he motivated by and on the
one hand you think well he was trying to
extend his cultural dominion right
played by his own self-consciousness ISM
he wanted to extend the the the borders
of his totalitarian certainty to every
corner just to not be plagued by the
unknown and you think fair enough you
know like we're all pretty nervous and
the little stability is a good thing why
because they make a fundamental judgment
which is the judgment of mephistopheles
look life is terrible terrible terrible
we're self-conscious we get sick we go
insane we're gonna die children innocent
children suffer everywhere how in the
world is it right to let such a state
continue maybe it would be better all
things considered just to bring the
whole game to an end and so then you
think again
with le ah de that the reason that human
societies fall apart is twofold one is
things go from bad to worse of their own
accord right thermodynamic reality pure
entropy structured entities decay but
then there's a twist structured entities
constructed by humans are sped in their
process of decay by the participants of
the individuals within that society who
have essentially decided that the game
is not worth the price and that under
such conditions the only reasonable
thing for a self-conscious
painfully self-conscious individual to
do is to work as hard as he or she
possibly can to take the maximum amount
of revenge on the conditions of
existence and to ensure that the entire
game folds up the consciousness
disappears and the being is eradicated
you